empire  is mine now  they're going to war  then we will be ready  we need muscle  you're looking for work  tell them it's on the house  the book of boba fett now streaming on  disney plus  i have to send a message  i'm the crime lord now  [Music]  this territory is mine  all belongs to me now  my name  is boba fett  the book of boba fett now streaming only  on disney plus  [Music]  jabba the hutt once sat upon that throne  [Music]  you all accrued wealth and riches under  jabba  you can again  [Music]  with this man  [Music]  boba fett  [Music]  what prevents us all from killing you  why speak of conflict  when cooperation can make us all rich  [Music]  i am not a bounty hunter  i'm the crime lord now  the book of boba fett streaming december  29th on disney plus  you